action what a [ __ ] omec gotta go back
[Music]
okay the story I have in front of me is
this 36 year old woman from Ohio was
arrested because she repeatedly called
her parents
okay I'm gonna face
[Music]
I mean when you make that so in other
words she wants cops to go to her does
she say she's a psychology student with
a 4.0 here's my thing I'm millennial
what I'm here talking about what's an
emergency to her yeah I'm a little more
open-minded to it okay okay
what's an emergency to you like to her
this is an emergency I lost my phone I
need my phone I use my phone a lot what
is not subjective Tiffany I know one
does not a subjective like like I
literally said I'm like or death
sometimes it is sometimes people like yo
I think this guy's trying to [ __ ]
attack me or some [ __ ] and nothing
happens
we all know that happens a lot I
actually call my own for that reason see
when so I always had just parked into my
apartment building this was recently no
this is back on like two thousand nine
or ten night I guess he goes nine and it
was really really dark and I didn't have
like my own parking space in this
apartment building I had to park on the
street so I parked on the street and
then there was this guy that was near me
and he walked up to my car and I got
really [ __ ] scared and I locked my
car and then he wouldn't leave he was
like lingering so I called the cops and
then I was shaking and then just
speaking to police just for some reason
makes me really really nervous
yeah it'll make you feel any better no I
was just I mean even it wasn't police is
an operation scratch yeah but still like
I'm just like Oh police scary I don't
know they should make you everyone sound
like Mickey Mouse no matter what you say
it like oh yeah uh-huh I hear you honey
and are you millennial and I guess and
then hear click
we got him calling cuz I'm like there's
a guy near my card
I can't get out cuz I'm scared like I
could you just send someone yeah and so
they were like ok I will send someone
and then he ended up leaving and that's
when I ran to my apartment so I don't
even know if the cops showed up oh yeah
it takes a little it takes a while and
minutes
well not least in Eliot stuck 22 in LA
yeah 6 minutes why I have a gun yes it's
a guns bro I have two guns I think of
now even 5 minutes is a long time people
understand like when an emergency
happens yeah too long it takes one
second for them to stab you go and
accent yeah so what are you supposed to
do wait you're not supposed to have a
gun in this house that's only people
that have a gun in here I'm caught a
voice and they're gonna get you please
hold mm-hmm that's funny though she's
like it is an emergency
I need to make sure that my phone is
instated so I can [ __ ] go to work or
whatever she's like I feel unsafe but
then no one's asking the important
question which is which is if her phone
is disconnected how she calling 9 or
what
I thought she was in a landline yeah
they were like a payphone Irfan that's
not landline I don't know the end they
won't answer that question either so
that's the most noise 4.0 student y'all
we got a respected yeah she's a 4.0
psychology student so it's not fair
maybe that's why sure maybe she's not
even a realtor maybe that's why she
still eats at home actually is they
pulled up like her profile or whatever
can you imagine buying a house from this
lady [ __ ] you actually sell luxury
homes cell phone puts on the flyer she's
like serious bars only and I knew there
and you're like I don't know me and my
wife we're just here to check it out and
she said serious buyers only excuse me I
have this guy right here yeah this guy I
said cheers buyers only like God why do
people do this this is like then
McDonald's story you get a McDonald
story every two weeks it's like they ran
on a chicken nuggets and somebody calls
now on one I'm like this is [ __ ] up
that makes sense I did that before for
what Joe Laurie machine broken always
broken after nine it's always broken I
why because they don't want to do it all
to clean it they don't want to do it you
don't want to do that but what did you
call it for same reason oh I just
concede okay I knew they were in or
underlying not for chicken nuggets I
told him did you know I am an official
McDonald's ambassador can I hold out a
brand deal and I said you see this [ __ ]
there I was like they're like yeah like
you've got me mother [ __ ] you got me
they didn't see me as an official
ambassador to they don't get like a card
or a badge or something it feels like
you're like the bottom tier you didn't
get the gold the gold arch yeah TIFF has
one Timmy have you seen that make
millions brother yes what's that why
it's so good so it's a show about how
the McDonald's Monopoly game was rigged
the entire team is on it it's a [ __ ]
Jake oh wait one free I won free
breakfast how about a million making a
million this is a documentary Timmy this
is documentary about Hall the big prize
is like the car the million dollars all
the cool things great nobody got rigged
out like you get free nugs you're like I
like that they didn't rig that I did
like the extra satisfice well I just got
the email to be an ambassador too so I'm
not about to talk about McDonald's at
McDonald's is involved in this
documentary
oh they are the the official from
McDonald's is in the documentary she's
talking do anything wrong wasn't it like
an employee or something boil it but
they they were pretty chill about so
it's like a separate company I was
putting on the contest I rigged the [ __ ]
okay sorry
you gotta watch it we know that if not
McDonald's is fault and so V Tompkins
still sponsors I like McDonald's fired
too who doesn't like had their new
quarter pounders
the what yeah their new quarter pounder
it's [ __ ] fire bro double
quarter-pounder and I put Mac sauce on
it and me tell you something Dave this
past year the Big Macs up you can order
that separately the double get the
double quarter-pounder and get max on
certain King says happier way but any
[ __ ]
any restaurant will do it your way but
so they got a new quarter pound they've
been doing for the past like a year or
two and it's like they switched
everything up like the new quarter
pounders like isn't froze its some [ __ ]
it's not frozen it's bomb bro it's so
good and that the Burger King slogan is
superfluous it is superfluous because
everybody does it the signs are purple
if it's a successful food it's not
necessary it's just yeah just were what
does frivolous mean frivolous is like
this is excessive it was excessive mean
it's for nothing no no no frivolous is
more like that's a [ __ ] reason it's
like a frivolous lawsuit it's working
something like that's all I know
frivolous being used with is lawsuits
privilege it's mostly used for that
frivolous you know it really don't mean
that
what was this article of that it's about
Oh Burger King it's like the last resort
a fast-food like hey burn key man it's
the worst of the worst of there's so
much mail in there I'm like get the full
bombshell knows the whopper no yo ones
listen my Braille the whopper is
actually whoppers [ __ ] fire was
delicious it's very inviting can we can
we do it it's higher loyal who in here
now that is gourmet but here's here's
what people sleep on
Burger King nuggets even though they're
really cheap or actually delicious but
you know what people really truly sleep
on is Wendy's spicy nuts
oh no one's sleeping dog people no sure
no well they know now cuz the chance the
rapper y'all eat a lot of fast food yeah
y'all not anymore I miss it
you're alive it's in the spank bank you
don't I do yeah it's a spank bank i
watch people eat it now on YouTube do
you do milk buns that's for watch people
eat what do you eat like salad no it
helps me I do that with only like Cajun
style like Lobster there's this one lady
that does it oh shoot that well I just
can't listen beloved [ __ ] is it the
black lady yeah oh my god can we get
some of that means a B just put out I
just put on my phones today me and Davey
eating a bunch of a crab a crab I don't
know what you guys need you go large I
wanna watch her eat seafood is so good
[Music]
[Music]